Hi and welcome to class.
I'm here with Jonathan and Ryan of academy which is an immersive program for
students to learn all about data science.
We're super excited to teach you guys about data visualization and
we want to kick off this class with one simple question.
So Jonathan, Ryan, what is data visualization?
>> Great question, Chris.
To me data visualization is about conveying a story or
an idea as efficiently as possible.
It's often said that a picture is worth 1,000 words and
I think data visualization works the same way.
Data scientists used data visualisation every day to explore patterns in
their data and to ultimately convey their results.
So we're super excited to share some of
what we teach our students with you today.
>> Cool. And Jonathan, what about you?
What do you think about data visualization?
>> Yeah, so I think the title of Edward Tufte's classic book,
The Visual Display of Quantitative Information actually get's at
a core of what many people think of as data visualization.
Simply, how best to represent visually some underlying data using things
like color, size, shape to convey some information or
some insight to their audience and their reader.
And I think it actually goes a little bit further than that
incorporating storytelling and narrative elements, like Ryan mentioned,
to let the author of data visualization tell some interesting insight
they've discovered on their own and they want to share it with their audience.
>> Interesting, thanks for sharing that guys.